después de dos años de pandemia vuelve
el festival folclórico de paran tings la
fiesta más importante de toda la
amazonía
durante tres días dos grupos rivales se
van a enfrentar aquí en el bombo dromo
son el boy garantido y el boy caprichoso
hoy es el último ensayo técnico del boy
garantido que ganó la última edición de
este festival en 2019 la expectativa es
enorme en una fiesta que celebra la
cultura indígena y la naturaleza
amazónica
pasamos pasamos dos años lejos de este
festival es una emoción muy fuerte y nos
preparamos para celebrar la fiesta del
buey y este festival en esta isla
realmente encantada
el chamán es la figura central de los
pueblos indígenas en el espectáculo de
este festival folclórico es el curandero
de la tribu que tiene el poder de ir al
mundo sobrenatural luchar contra los
seres maléficos que causan los males en
la aldea y traer la cura para el pueblo
[Música]
durante tres días en esta arena llamada
bomba o dromo habrá 100.000 espectadores
en la última edición en 2019
66 mil eran turistas en su mayoría de la
región amazónica pero también del resto
de brasil y de países extranjeros porque
esta fiesta no solo tiene un gran valor
cultural y folclórico también mueve 10
millones de dólares en cada edición el
domingo sabremos quién es el ganador de
este festival el rojo o el azul el
garantido o el caprichoso
[Música]